this is my living room
nice this is my kitchen you'll never use
it
hey I can cook a little bit Oh your
mom's worried you got starve to death
yeah well I'm not going here
kind of again I keep getting these weird
text messages
are you feeling okay out there
mom it's so amazing here um it's about
if I know yes it I'm Michael by the way
Emma I'll text you
that's her number uh he's really cute
wait till the person I did I was saying
someone back home but we broke up uh
speak the devil it's Alex my ass it's
854 Wilson Avenue apartment 4a apartment
4a can you take a picture of us let me
put my number in first it's the least I
can do
wait all your photos are gone know that
all is I'm just certain ones I'm so pure
now I just flex [ __ ] gonna
congratulate let go
look or just go home my door wasn't
locked I never do that
pop your head I'm proud of you mom I
want to hug you right now I want to hug
you right now
on you right now I knew
diagnostician is some kurdish yet
spanish and a higher